a source tells ET justin bieber and
Haley Baldwin are married it's no secret
that the Biebs and the 21 year old model
are smitten with each other but the
couple is fueling marriage rumors after
making a surprise visit to Canada Justin
took his ladylove to the Stratford Perth
Museum in Ontario where there is an
exhibit called Justin Bieber steps to
stardom dedicated to his career it was
really a special moment for me check out
this sweet handwritten note Haley posted
on the belieber wall that read
I heart you forever Haley beam in the
comment section of Instagram the museum
gave more details about the Pierre
surprise visit
riding Justin very graciously introduced
Haley as his wife perhaps just a term of
endearment we loved their visit we have
a good time together he's just really
sweet he's a good kid
it's a good heart and I love him the
sorry singer reportedly tied the knot in
secret with Baldwin last month in New
York City the same day the lovebirds got
their marriage license at a courthouse
our ET source says Justin and Haley
didn't want to wait to be married adding
quote they still plan to have a more
formal wedding but for them this
intimate ceremony was exactly what they
wanted Justin and Haley have yet to
publicly address the status of their
relationship but their PDA makes us all
a believer
[Music]